il faut d'abord
nominé
on est au 10 juillet
tu vas d'opale roulettes ont souillé
mont joli bouquet
toujours sympa oui d'accord escape
limité pour laquelle vous avez dit vers
l'est qui dépend de vous indiquer la
montagne et à bumba choisi par dizaines
d'années
la partie miremont briller bonjour je
m'appelle semble un sujet qui chauffait
depuis 89 et j'ai la passion pour les
petits bébés
c'est un gars me vendra pas chez bonjour
je m'appelle jessica les deux
paul et l'influent juste arrivé à la
gare de saint denis
je peux je suis en famille bien bronzé
aux matelles daniela et
je suis un vrai roulant de peinture
d'années et je vais pour la première
fois prendre les cars jaunes qui sont
équipés pour les personnes en un an et
demi qui réduit les pony games tout
danger bonjour je m'appelle rémi 18 ans
salutations pierres sur des scellés
l'horizon est là entraînant ce saint
pierre a vu que nouvelle ligne de bus
réalité la ligne b en deux mots c'est à
dire au sens de la gare routière où
exactement elle a pas exactement mais en
passant par ses ennuis saint paul la
salle saint leu qui parle à l'arrêt au
roi de roland garros il avait jour
bonjour à ses côtés voilà j'ai joué
savoir s'il était possible de prendre
les cars et carte jaune
puisque je suis en fauteuil roulant en
direction vous allez me suite à mes
côtés j'ai même rendre au zona de l'état
épargne à la paix moi je trouve le
confronte à bijoux qui mathis v et avec
les prix vsd par exemple au siège ici
c'est bien ce qu'il n'y avait jamais eu
ça dans la colonne du tout c'est
d'arriver dans le nouveau bus ou c'est
confortable justement pour ne pas
pratiquer par rapport la poussette c'est
d'être au niveau du coffre est chaud
comme j'ai un bébé de quatre mois
c'est plus pratique pour moi par rapport
à la rampe
voilà variés du bruit ça c'est très
maniable
ça nous plaît vraiment aider les
handicapés surtout et puis pour les
poussettes pour les bébés ces masses
pratique à ce point d'eau les dirigeants
je pense que c'est un projet qui est
formidable pour les personnes à mobilité
réduite qui n'ont jamais eu l'occasion
deviez pleinement donc je pense que pour
cette formidable moyen d'aller d'un
point à un autre et je souhaite que
mes congénères french débute le plus
possible pour leur permettent de
d'aller là où bon leur semble
ce nouveau cas là c'est pour moi c'est
très bien très adaptable
maniable surtout et puis bon se sent à
l'aise il ya la clim il y avait tout - -
fatigué - c'est aussi de l'odeur comme
la montée essentielle au top secret de
maija combat c'est magnifique que je
pense qu'il a pas que moi qui sera
satisfait de la jolie doute du fait que
la plage et handicapés pourront prendre
en avant les cars jaunes a adapté aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
j'ai apprécié ce voyage lien n'existe
pas alors reprendre
ça y est arrivé à la garde
et
temps de venir dans le bus je
n'hésiterai plus à la
gâtés à sortir de chez moi pour l'heure
le carré
vos profils à l'emploi j'ai pas avant
on ne peut que féliciter le conseil
général il ya l'idée se poser en
espérant que les
je pouvais handicap et personnes à
mobilité réduite pourront facilement se
déplacer grh et par dessus tout ça fait
plaisir de moi c'est non
c'est en égalité sur jeunesse merci
beaucoup d'être plaisir à tous les papas
secteur du port bouët papa aujourd'hui
mais pas c'est clair je dois sweet papa